ma mère était une excellente musicienne
et je pense que c'est finalement elle
qui m'a inspiré qui m'a amené un
musicien moi-même
alors Sting vous avez vendu plus de 100
millions d'albums dans le monde depuis
le début de votre carrière parfois on
dit Sting en moins en fait votre avant
dernier album s'est vendu à 7 millions
d'exemplaires et sacré de Love en est à
6 millions pour le moment ça va
ça va c'est supportable ça va bien c'est
mieux que Dany Brillant
[Rires]
vous avez pas eu de numéro 1 single
depuis longtemps mais les albums se
vendent bien quoi
et moi je fais surtout les albums c'est
alors vous dites peut-être qu'un jour
mes disques ne trouveront plus leur
public
ça peut arriver vous y pensez ça vous
inquiète
Noah
du cœur alors si les gens ne comprennent
c'est très bien sinon je continuerai à
faire le même musique vos formerez pas
police si ça marche pas non non alors
vous avez dit qu'à l'occasion du rock n'
roll of Fame vous avez reformé police et
vous dites j'ai retrouvé finalement une
ambiance pas géniale du tout
un peu prématuré ça ne fait que 20 ans
que le groupe c'est démantelé il faut un
peu plus de temps pour redevenir
sentimental commencer à être nostalgique
dans 10 ans mais c'est vrai que police a
pas été une aventure très très
sentimentale très très romantique
c'était assez dur à l'intérieur du
groupe les rapports entre vous non
et c'était c'était
comme un mariage sans sexe si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire oui je vois c'est
terrible alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes très riche et très
célèbre mais vous dites quand même je
ferai ce boulot même si c'était pour
rien même si j'étais pas payé bien sûr
je continuerai même pour les chats s'il
le fallait je peux pas m'empêcher de
chanter il faut que je chante vous avez
toujours la flamme quoi
alors désormais on sait d'où vient cette
flamme puisque vous publiez Sting chez
Robert Laffont un livre qui s'appelle
broken Music qui raconte les 25
premières années de votre vie le livre
commence en 1987 vous êtes à Rio de
Janeiro et vous assistez à un office
religieux dans une église perdue dans la
jungle qui qui en sert la ville et vous
participez à un rythme basé sur
l'absorption d'une plante psychotrope
qui s'appelle Laya Waska c'est un
liquide sacré une potion magique dans la
véhicule et comparable à la sérotonine
au moment de boire ce liquide brun épais
comme ça que vous comparez à l'huile de
vidange vous dites ma femme et moi nous
échangeons un regard désespéré un regard
de deux amants qui s'apprêtent à sauter
ensemble d'une falaise c'est gonflé
quand même de
prendre ça comme ça non vous aviez pas
peur des conséquences des séquelles ça
pouvait avoir sur votre esprit
à house very intrigue
intrigué par ce rituel
et c'est un petit peu comme une
expérience de quasiment
se rappellent toute sa vie en un éclair
ou disons en quatre ou cinq heures
disons que tout vous repasse dans la
tête et puis on s'interroge
psychologiquement sur les raisons de ce
que l'on est donc c'est une expérience
extrêmement profonde très sérieuse je
dois dire mais en même temps je ne le
regrette pas alors ce jour-là vous êtes
à quelques jours de donner le plus grand
concert de votre carrière solo 200000
personnes vous attendent au stade de
maracania à Rio de Janeiro vous venez de
perdre vos parents et l'ingestion de
cette plante de l'âme comme vous
l'appelez provoque chez vous un
véritable séisme intérieur au départ
vous revivez une vie antérieure et vous
vous retrouvez soldat en 1916 dans la
bataille de la Somme mais vous n'avez
pas eu de grand-père qui soit dans la
barre vous avez pas eu de proches qui
qui est vécu ça
par contre il y avait des gens dans mon
village qui était mort en Belgique ou
dans le nord de la France pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale donc il y a
quand même une espèce de lien c'est qui
psychique je ne sais pas
c'était un peu comme si j'étais là quand
même ça rejoint un peu l'inconscient
collective de Carl Lyon c'est à dire des
images qu'on aurait tous dans la tête
finalement c'est ça
et je pense qu'une bataille est un
événement un événement psychique
formidable enfin
50000 personnes qui me rendent le coup
ça crée une énergie des vibrations
terribles ça c'est la première
expérience que vous vivez après avoir
ingéré cette cette plante ensuite vous
vivez une expérience de régression vous
vous retrouvez dans le ventre de votre
mère et puis assis à ses pieds pendant
qu'elle joue du piano et là vous nous
parlez de votre mère qui est très belle
qui a des longs cheveux blonds des yeux
verts enfin qui est une très belle femme
vous regardez ses chaussures pointues
quand elles jouent du piano appuyé sur
les sur les pédales vous votre votre
enfance la maison victorienne humide
sans chauffage central
j'avais pas le choix à l'époque
c'était mes parents ma vie n'était pas
particulièrement heureux lorsque j'étais
enfant mais quand j'ai écrit ce livre
j'ai appris à apprécier ce que mes
parents m'ont donné parce que c'est
grâce à eux que je suis venu ce que je
suis et je leur suis reconnaissant donc
mes deux parents sont morts aujourd'hui
mais d'une certaine façon je les ai
expliqué au monde entier enfin j'espère
alors il y a un moment très difficile
dans votre vie dans votre enfance et
quand votre père lâche son métier pour
devenir gérant d'une crème riz à partir
de là il va énormément travailler
pratiquement 7 jours sur 7 et puis il a
des problèmes financiers un jour il y a
une image terrible c'est quatre hommes
qui arrivent avec une blouse brune et
qui emporte le piano de la maison dans
une camionnette bleue
nous étions pauvres à l'époque
bon maintenant je suis peut-être riche
mais
j'apprécie chaque centime que j'ai gagné
est la liberté que cela m'apporte je
considère pas ça comme normal parce que
je sais ce que c'est que de ne pas avoir
d'argent mais mes parents travaillaient
dur c'était des gens bien c'était des
gens honorables vous dites le jour où le
piano est parti ce jour-là j'ai vu
quelque chose mourir sur les sur les
traits de ma mère
ouais
ma mère était une excellente musicienne
et je pense que c'est finalement elle
qui m'a inspiré qui m'a amené des
musiciens moi-même
une respiration que que je porte
jusqu'au jour donc je suis encore
reconnaissant et puis votre mère tombe
amoureuse d'un employé de la crèmerie
pour vous ça a été un choc terrible il y
a une scène assez forte un jour vous
découvrirez les amants et vous dites
deux ombres derrière des carreaux
opaques brusquement nous sommes une
famille condamné à la mort dans un avion
en chute libre
je ne suis pas le premier enfant qui
était moins de ce genre de choses
d'infidélité conjugale mais pour moi
disons que cela a éclairé ma vie d'une
certaine façon et à l'image de ma mère
je suis un romantique désespéré je crois
en l'amour romantique mais lorsque le
mariage n'apporte pas cet amour menti
qui est bien vous le cherchez ailleurs
là l'expression tu veux le beurre
l'argent du beurre et le cul de la crème
votre père votre père était quelqu'un
d'assez d'assez froide assez réservé non
qui avait du mal à vous dire qui vous
aimez
mal il était né entre les deux guerres
dans les années 20 et la plupart des
hommes avaient du mal à exprimer leur
amour ne pouvait pas l'exprimer et alors
il ne l'a dit qu'à la fin de sa vie en
fait
et je l'aime moi-même voilà donc
effectivement une enfance pas très
heureuse Sting et vous trouvez refuge
dans la musique vous découvrez les les
Beatles c'est là d'un seul coup vous
vous voyez des gens finalement qui
viennent de la même origine sociale que
vous parce que les Beatles c'est
Liverpool ils vivaient pas mieux que
vous à Newcastle je me suis dit si eux
ils arrivaient à conquérir le monde par
la musique et même moi aussi je pouvais
en faire autant là commence vos rêves de
vos rêves de gloire vous découvrez aussi
à la même époque Jimi Hendrix
il est venu dans ma ville je l'ai vu
jouer
figurez-vous j'avais jamais vu quelqu'un
jouer la guitare de la main gauche
j'avais jamais vu de popstar qui était
en même temps un virtuose de la musique
donc il m'a vraiment inspiré et c'est
lui qui m'a poussé à essayer de limiter
voilà alors des années après vous
décidez vous aussi de tenter votre
chance dans la capitale vous partez pour
Londres vous racontez la rencontre de
votre deuxième femme qui est votre femme
actuelle true dystyler alors vous tombez
amoureux d'elle c'est l'heure de firside
dès que vous la voyez vous tombez
amoureux elle vous apporte du thé là
d'un seul coup vous tombez et vous
mettrez 3 ans avant de vous mettre trois
ans avant de faire l'amour avec elle
parce que peut-être à cause de ce que
vous aviez vécu dans votre enfance vous
vouliez pas casser le couple que vous
formiez avec Francis
mais c'est vrai que je suis tombé
amoureux de Trudy immédiatement il m'a
fallu trois ans trois ans de torture
avant d'arriver à mes femmes et je me
suis rendu compte que elle était mon
partenaire mais qu'est-ce que tu penses
des filles qui couchent la première
décennie c'est pas un peu c'est pas un
peu des allumeuse
très sympa je trouve voilà et vous
racontez Sting la naissance de votre
premier tube
[Musique]
alors vous êtes à Paris c'est à Paris
que ça a été créé il est à Paris dans un
hôtel miteux un hôtel borgne derrière la
gare Saint-Lazare il y a une réception
absolument crapoteuse avec une affiche
de la Comédie Française Cyrano de
Bergerac yes
en fait la maîtresse de Cyrano de
Bergerac s'appelait Roxane rappelez-vous
et dans la rue en bas il y avait des
prostituées et
je trouvais que les deux choses étaient
liées et donc j'ai écrit cette chanson
triste
ce que c'est que d'être la mort d'une
femme qui travaille dans quel trottoir
cette chanson tous les soirs voilà et
puis police va devenir un des plus
grands groupes du monde et vous dites
célèbre et riche à un point absurde
voilà
j'étais tellement occupé à gagner de
l'argent que j'ai pas le temps de le
dépenser jusqu'au moment où je suis
rentré de ma deuxième ou troisième
tournée j'ai vu un peu ce qu'il y avait
sur mon compte en banque et c'était
effectivement absurde je me suis rendu
compte que je peux m'acheter une maison
comme ça si je voulais
malheureusement tu n'as pas acheté de
rotunnels donc tu n'as pas perdu
[Rires]
voilà ça s'appelle broken music c'est
les mémoires de Sting les 25 premières
années de sa vie est-ce qu'il va y avoir
un tome 2
je sais pas
c'était doux pour moi dur ouais mais
c'est bien écrit c'est bien c'est pas
juste non non c'est très littéraire on
peut dire vraiment bravo
voilà donc signe à l'album qui s'appelle
ça comme Love et le bouquin qui
s'appelle broken music ça veut dire la
musique en morceau la broken music c'est
la musique en miette en pièces quoi
c'est votre grand-mère qui vous disait
ça elle vous disait arrête de jouer de
la broken music non
la musique était en mille morceaux mais
j'ai passé ma vie entière à essayer de
recoller les morceaux de la musique
justement j'espère y avoir réussi bien
Sting est-ce que vous êtes prêt pour un
mardi view
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez à quoi en ce moment là
je pense à votre prochaine invité quand
vous vous regardez dans la glace le
matin vous vous dites quoi
je vois mon père
de plus en plus et il te dit quoi ton
père dans la glace
non
je suis pas mort vous auriez aimé
ressembler à qui quand vous étiez petit
voilà votre plus belle histoire d'amour
c'est laquelle
de ce rêve my wife de mon épouse Troudi
quand avez-vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois
[Musique]
vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
pour moi d'argent peut-être
j'aimerais bien avoir votre esprit ah
c'est gentil
quel est le péché qui vous tente le plus
de vice sexe
ce n'est pas propre
qu'est-ce que vous pourriez dire de plus
négatif sur vous
si votre vie était à refaire qu'est-ce
que vous changeriez
quel est l'insulte qui vous a fait le
plus mal
que feriez-vous s'il ne vous restez que
24 heures à vivre
mais l'amour
avec sa femme pendant 8 heures une fois
et moi 12h avec ta femme
signe avez-vous déjà pensé à vous
suicider
parce que quand ça va trop bien comme ça
[Rires]
il est arrivé Julio Iglesias
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez repris une chanson de Sting et
de tous les chansons
bien votre chanson Julio oh
avec beaucoup d'années
latin chanson empreinte de la dignité
c'est formidable vous vous connaissez
bien tous les deux
chez moi pour enregistrer cette chanson
et puis il m'a envoyé toute une caisse
de vin en retour donc c'est très gentil
voilà je dois dire que
c'était pour moi une des plus belles
chansons jamais écrit
qu'il était vraiment
tu veux te voir à Waterloo si tu vois ça
je suis très d'abord il faut que je dise
que je suis une très très grande
animateur de Sting et surtout faut que
je dise que sans doute c'est un génie de
la musique un grand génie de la musique
ça je le dis avec beaucoup de la
composition
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu